if you switched genders for a day what
is the first thing you would do I'm
Donnie and if you switch genders for a
day what was the last image do you stand
up or sit down when you're wiping your
bum don't sit down thank you
okay what is your most embarrassing
interaction with a famous person
no no just a take your time are you
serious what is Marcus Rochefort sexiest
feature teeth Grisi Oh
what is your sexiest feature kind of
reveals to you ah if you go back in time
and erase one thing you did what would
you is would you rather when the
Champions League with my United or the
World Cup with England's that's a
question I you know oh you know most
both both both still plenty of time here
what is something that no one else knows
about you
Oh who was your least favorite player to
play with have you peed in the shower in
the past year yeah yeah today today is
the last question this is who do you
need to hit the buzzer automatically
have you ever pretended to be sick to
get out of something if so yeah well all
the times goers it's not laughing like
this commercial activity or sometimes
not today concern is Jesse mm-hmm thank
you very much thanks Ron pleasure